[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm John Connolly The Spectators
news editor and your host for this week
coming up on the show
we're only a month into Hamza USA's
leadership of the SMP this party seems
to have imploded with senior members of
the s p facing arrest resignations and
police Searchers so it's the end of the
party and with that Independence Andrew
Neil joins me on the show
as world leaders fly to Belfast for the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement who are Ireland's Violent Men
of Peace Douglas Murray takes a look for
this week's magazine he joins me on the
show along with Arlene Foster
for our cover piece this week Louise
Perry and Paul Morgan Bentley share
their views on surrogacy Louise joins me
on the show followed by Kim cotton who
is the UK's first surrogate mother
and finally is it wrong for Netflix to
portray Cleopatra as black in their new
series some may think it's an Erasure of
history but does that matter I'm joined
by Professor David abalafia
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
and if you want to read more from The
Spectator then why not subscribe to the
magazine as well for just 12 pounds you
can get 12 weeks in print and online and
a free 20 pound Amazon voucher just go
to spectator.co.uk forward slash TV
offer to subscribe
to kick things off we're starting with
the state of the SNP I'm here now with
the spectators chairman Andrew Neal
who's been following the story closely
right thank you Andrew for joining us on
spectator TV now in the sort of past
month or so since Nicholas sturgeon
resigned we've had for the SMP we've had
arrests resignations arguments over
membership levels a fractious leadership
election and in all your time looking at
politics have you ever seen the
implosion of a political party like this
uh I was ignore I've never seen
something unravel as quickly as this of
a party uh unraveling I mean of course
Liz trusses government unraveled pretty
quickly and uh I saw one comment
commentators say that in the scale of
disasters it's somewhere between the
Hindenburg and Liz truss and I think
that probably does put it in the right
context I mean we would never have
thought this even two months ago we
would never have thought that Nicola
sturgeon's departure would lead to the
unraveling of the position of the SNP in
Scotland and indeed the unraveling of
the independence courts in Scotland as
well it is a remarkable change I mean
only Shakespeare could cover you know
what a falling off there was and we
haven't yet had the police report we
haven't yet the police are still uh in
the middle or coming towards the end of
their inquiries that then as you say a
number of arrests I see speculation in
the Scottish media that even Nicholas
sturgeon might be arrested and taken in
for questioning I mean that is just
incredible so it's a story that is no by
no means over uh yet it's probably going
to get worse before it gets better uh we
still don't know what this happened to
the 600 000 pounds they read I see
there's now a rather expensive camper
van in the equation as well I mean only
in British politics got a camper van the
uh uh a credible piece of evidence so
let's see where it unravels however it
unravels cannot be to the benefit of the
SMP I mean what do you think the
Scottish public make of this I mean they
must be just looking on with complete
bafflement that this sort of domineering
party that sort of dominated Scottish
politics for years is now is now in
complete Anarchy
well only a few months ago Nicholas
dungeon could walk on water no she uh
even stepping over a puddle is dangerous
for her she uh she isn't waving she's
drowning and uh I the Scottish public
um are amazed at what's happened I don't
think the wholly understand it uh I
think it has discredited the SNP in the
eyes of the voters uh a party that
hitherto has dominated Scottish politics
and will in his own way I suspect still
remain the largest party but it's not
Invincible anymore it is not the voice
of Scotland anymore the way it has liked
to portray itself and I suppose the best
the context to see this is what is
happening is
the inevitable denomal of what happens
in one party States
that you've had the SMP Riding High on
the hog for a long long time now almost
for a generation uh unchallenged by any
of the other political parties in
Scotland with a rather tame media which
in many areas have been cheerleaders for
it with a bubble in Hollywood and in
Edinburgh where they only there's no one
there to criticize her or the SNP indeed
of anything they want to cheer to go
further on a party that's gotten Hawk to
the radical Greens in Scotland as well
and I suppose in some way and also you
just can't question it we saw that video
of Nicholas dungeon who got quite Surety
when anyone dared to suggest that the
finances of the SMP were anything but
Rosie and pristine and so I think all
that comes from being in power for too
long being unchallenged for too long by
not having an aggressive and robust
enough media for too long as well
although it was in the end bound to come
to an end in some sticky way I certainly
never foresaw that it would come to an
end in a tragedy of Shakespearean
proportions certainly spectacular
um where does this leave Hamza Yusuf now
I mean he's tried to relaunch his party
twice now it's obviously been
overshadowed by other events do you do
you think he even has the capability to
sort of lead the party through this
well when this week he made his big kind
of state of the union or what he would
like it to be instead of the breakup of
the Union uh Speech uh about how he was
going to run things in the weeks months
or years ahead
almost no one took any notice it was
overshadowed by all the other events
we've been talking about and I think
that's part of his problem uh the other
events overshadow what he's trying to do
and no one's much interested in what
he's trying to do as a result and indeed
most dangerous
for all politicians is not when they're
being criticized politicians are always
criticized even for a time they can be
ignored you can survive that too things
can swing back in your favor but as I
look at the coverage of them uh across
the Spectrum he's become an object of
derision
that's very dangerous for politicians
when you're deriding treated as a joke
character not taken seriously that I
don't know how you recover for that and
I I would say they're all supporters of
the union and those who want to see
Scotland and England remain in the union
that is the United Kingdom I suspect
there ought to be crossing the figures
that the current first Minister remains
first Minister for the foreseeable
future uh because I think it's
impossible for him to deliver on the
breakup of the United Kingdom if
Nicholas sturgeon couldn't do it I see
no way that he is going to be able to do
it either so at the moment he is
probably the best guarantor of the
continued Union between Scotland and and
England at the moment and I think if
Miss Forbes his main rival was to take
over she'd be a more formidable figure
and I see a lot of commentary of people
saying he may not I'll be around for
long you know they'll do badly now
they'll lose seats to labor in the
general election they'll lose even more
seats to the next holy red election he
won't be there for long he'll be
replaced I think if you believe in the
union you want to keep your fingers
crossed that doesn't uh happen but it's
a it's a grim time for the SNP it's a
grim time for those who want to break up
the United Kingdom as a grim time for
the independence uh movement uh at at
the moment and I would say that
the union seems to me
to be as safe as it has been since
Scotland voted 55-45 to remain in the
Union in that referendum way back in
2014. would you go as far to say even
that um Independence has an issue has
been buried for a generation even or do
you think that's pushing it too much
well the problem is in Scotland we don't
know what a generation is
we were told that uh that the last
referendum had settled the matter indeed
Nicholas sturgeon implied that it had
settled the matter for a generation it
turns out that of course a generation in
Scotland maybe only five years or 10
years
and of course given male longevity in
the west of Scotland which is among the
lowest in the Western World maybe that
is the correct generation uh the correct
definition of generation in Scotland uh
gone for a generation we live in a world
where things can change very quickly
but it isn't just the crisis that
currently faces the SNP which then
becomes a crisis for the independent
movement because the SNP is the Vanguard
is the vehicle by which Independence was
meant to happen all the questions that
were raised in the 2014 referendum
particularly the economic questions uh
about what currency would be used would
there be a border between Beric and
Carlisle how easy would it be for an
independent Scotland to rejoin the EU
how would you finance the budget deficit
on Independence which currently is
financed by the rest of the Union
how could you borrow in a new currency
all these questions which were important
in 2014 they're even more important now
and not one of these questions has been
convincingly answered so whoever is
running the SMP even if they were
managed to get the show back on the road
after this car crash of a period they've
still got these questions to answer and
they've not come close in any way to
doing so so I think John Libya
generation out is not uh it's certainly
gone as a prospect Independence for the
foreseeable future and it may be now
that the SMP implosion has kind of left
a bit of a vacuum at the center of
Scottish politics do you get the sense
that labor are the ones who can really
benefit out of this or are they not also
it's not propositions that will benefit
from this by how much we don't know uh
the Tories can benefit from them because
they're the party of government in
Westminster and there will be a empty
government votes not just in Scotland
but throughout the United Kingdom that
is just a price you pay if you've been
in power for the number of years the
Tories have been in power since 2010
so labor is the party that will benefit
uh and that will help Kia starma in his
efforts to form the next government
uk-wide how many seats he will get well
no no Prospect of going back to the days
when the Scottish labor party had over
40 seats in Scotland and helped to form
governments in uh in Westminster I would
be surprised if they even got more than
20 seats but they could get 15. they
could pick up it's just why I said
earlier the SNP for all its travails and
all the Messes in in my view is still
likely to remain the biggest party in
Scotland for some time to come yet it's
just people have got used to voting that
way but it pays a price for that
increasingly it's become the party of
central Scotland uh of the central belt
between Glasgow and Edinburgh and less
and less the party where it started
which is the more rural areas in the
northeast of Scotland the prosperous
north east of Scotland but it's worried
about Labor and it's coming out with
policies designed to appeal to that
former labor vote in the west of
Scotland in particular it will pay a
price for that labor will pick up a
number of these seats and the greater uh
Glasgow region and even 15 would be a
big help to kill stamina I think at the
moment he's got one 15 last time my
Loops would be 15 times the seats he's
got he's got now so I think it is going
to go to some extent Labor's way
brilliant thank you very much Andrew
next world leaders are in Belfast to
Mark 25 years of the Good Friday
agreement but can Northern Ireland ever
move on when the violence of the
troubles has not truly been acknowledged
I'm joined Now by spectator columnist
Douglas Murray and former leader of the
dup now broadcaster Arlene Foster
Douglas Arlene thank you for joining us
on spectator TV now Douglas you write in
the magazine this week about people who
are involved in the troubles now being
held up and lauded as Heroes and sort of
men of Peace um can you tell us a bit
about that to get us started
uh yes it's something which as I
mentioned in my column inspected this
week it is not new we've just had the
25th anniversary celebrations of the
Good Friday agreement we had of course
Joe Biden flying into Northern Ireland
for a matter of hours then doing a sort
of family trip around uh the Republic of
Ireland for a week or so
um we had the clintons arriving in
Northern Ireland for a conference and a
lot of people claiming uh credit for the
agreement and I mentioned in my peace uh
you know let's not be sort of ungracious
about this the Good Friday agreement has
meant that violence in Northern Ireland
has been down significantly for the last
30 years it's not gone away as many
people on the mainland seem to think
um but we haven't had 3 000 more bodies
thank goodness there's an enormous
amount that an incalculable amount that
must be said for it but one of the
things I say the dissenting note I I I
put in is is one that I've tried to put
in before which is that
um for many of us it remains galling to
see the people and I'm thinking in
particular here of Jerry Adams caught in
a smiling selfie with President Joe
Biden seeing these people being
venerated as men of peace who actually
were exactly the opposite of that and
what I've said and lest anyone think
that I've sort of um you know ignorant
of the things that went on on all sides
here remind people when I wrote a book
on Bloody Sunday 12 years ago I attended
the Savile hearings for many years into
in into the atrocity of Bloody Sunday
um I'm not ignoring problems on any or
all sides but it is exceptionally
galling that as I mentioned in that book
uh the people who said don't shoot
people in the head whatever the
circumstances kept being left behind and
the people who believed in shooting
people in the head for 30 years and then
suddenly said actually let's not do that
and now Lord it as the men of Peace it's
still extremely hard to stomach and I
always fear that when we take the wrong
lessons from history the likelihood of
repeating it is except nationally high
and Arlene what do you make of that I
mean is there a case that some people
will make that we kind of need to put
the fans behind us and not maybe not
turn a blind eye to it but kind of move
on from that or or are you in more
agreement with Douglas there well first
of all I mean I remember the events of
25 years ago very well well indeed and
I've listened to
various speakers over this last couple
of days talking about
um the need to say yes and they should
people should show leadership by saying
yes and actually 25 years ago I said no
to the Belfast agreement and the reason
I did that was because the agreement
allowed terrorists to leave jail
without any attention given in the
agreement to those people who had paid
the ultimate that who had lost their
loved ones whose loved ones had been
murdered uh by the very people that were
being let out of prison and I found that
not only morally objectionable and it
was and is morally objectionable but
also what message was outstanding to
people who had conducted violence for a
long period of time what it sent the
message to them that actually
um in exchange for you stopping your
violence and in exchange for killing
people uh you will now be able to stand
as a member of the legislative assembly
you will be able to come a minister in
the government but yet and we know this
very well don't we the legacy of what
happened all those years ago still
hasn't been dealt with and victims are
still hurting and what I found
incredible yesterday was the Secretary
of State for no Northern Ireland Chris
Heaton Harris at the very large
conference which is largely Americans
coming along and speaking to other
academics and and people from the Irish
government and people from the UK
government and all congratulating
themselves and what a wonderful job
they've done Chris Heaton Harris give a
speech where he praised wait for it the
courage and Leadership of Jerry Adams
and Martin McGinnis
which I I just find very difficult and I
think of all those victims who are
listening to that and I've looked at
some of their uh social media accounts
today and frankly they are absolutely
outraged they're very hurt and this just
isn't victims from one side of the
community to take up Douglas's point
this is victims from right across the
community who feel that they are just
forgotten about and instead we're going
to glorify the people who are actually
involved in murdering people for 25 30
years and what went through your head
Arlene when you saw that picture of
Jerry Adams and Joe Biden together as a
in a selfie
well I wasn't incredible you know I
wasn't surprised by that at all and I'm
sure Douglas wasn't surprised either
because uh President Joe Biden um has
long been a friend of the Irish
Republican and a movement
um he was photographed with Rita O'Hare
who was on the run from UK authorities
from 1972 for him her involvement in
relation to the murder or the sorry the
attempted murder of a soldier here in
Northern Ireland she then went on the
run and was wanted up until the time of
her death just a month ago but he had no
difficulty in standing for a photograph
with radio O'Hare so it doesn't surprise
me at all uh that he that he stands for
a photograph with Jerry Adams
and Douglas she mentioned in your piece
that you say after the peace process you
know there's been sort of this poison in
on the Northern Ireland that hasn't been
rooted out I mean do you link it to sort
of the rise in a bit of sectarian
violence that we've seen recently for
example in the run up to the 25-year
anniversary
um
the problem is that it hasn't gone away
and the Good Friday agreement didn't
make it go away
my own prediction has always been that
the IRA would be back because it was
throughout the 20th century and it was
because the poison tree has not been
uprooted
I mentioned in the piece my late friend
Sean o'callaghan who acted as a double
agent within the Army Council of the IRA
a man who exceptional bravery who's my
great honor to be friends with
um Sean spent the last years of his life
writing among other things a biography
of of James Connolly one of the heroes
of 1916 and I remember when I asked him
why he was devoting his his what time he
had left to this he said Connolly was
the man who radicalized me and made me
do Terrible Things Sean himself as a
young man killed people in Cold Blood
believing this terrible cause he said I
want to go up go back and dig that tree
up I want I I want to to get the poison
out I want to do whatever I can so that
it's not still there so that the poison
tree doesn't keep bearing bloody fruit
but when I look at pictures from the
Kragen in recent days and of of
teenagers who don't remember the
troubles going out with petrol bombs and
gleefully entertaining themselves you
see once again that toxic mixture of
boredom
Romanticism and veneration of violence
that is still there and that's the
cocktail that's the cocktail I mean
remember one of the books that the
Provost and others still hate most is
malachiodocates the the trouble with
guns and the reason they hate it is
because audacity in that book highlights
precisely this you know the way in which
in Republican newspapers to this day
people sort of say you know uh uh
commemorating are are much loved Son you
know who's now with the angels you know
who sort of blew himself up whilst
trying to make an IED to put in a
butcher's shop you know this sort of
toxic poison tree is still there and you
know the politicians in Westminster and
Washington like to think it isn't but it
is and they've done nothing to address
it and in the case of Joe Biden I'm
afraid he and other senior Democrats
like Chuck Schumer who spoke a couple of
years ago the show in Fame conference
calling for United Ireland which is I
always remind people is as outrageous as
an MP from Westminster going to America
and calling for Texas to succeed from
the union Chuck Schumer Joe Biden the
senior Democrats they continue to
actually water the poison tree they
continue to do so read some of the
Boston newspapers on any of this they're
more radical than anything written on
the radical left of the British uh uh
journalistic system I'll indeed take
such a Negative view do you think that
Poison's still there do you think there
is still the capacity for sectarian
violence in Isle in Northern Ireland
part of the difficulty is we allow the
glorification of past terrorism to
continue and whilst of course uh those
of us who live in Northern Ireland are
very thankful that we don't live in the
70s and 80s which I grew up in and and
and and I'm really glad that my children
don't have to deal with that on a day
and daily basis but the glorification of
terrorism continues and therefore you
will see the leaders of shin Fein go go
to commemorations for people who frankly
were murderers and uh one that I know
very well is Sheamus mcalwind who killed
a number of people in County fermanagh
tried to kill my own father because he
was a police officer and didn't succeed
on that occasion because he was very
young at that time but he went on to
kill a lot of people and Martin McGinnis
used to go to that commemoration every
year and talk about a what a wonderful
person Sheamus McElwain was and that has
an impact on young people because they
look at that and they say oh this man
must have been a great man and look what
he did for Ireland so-called and that
has an impact and now then you get into
um the situation where young people
today from a republican background don't
think there's anything wrong with
chanting about the IRA who are up there
are they will chant in your face as if
it's some cultural right that they have
to do that whereas in actual fact they
are loading people who used to go out
and murder their neighbors on country
roads in Northern Ireland and it's wrong
and I think government have a
responsibility to deal with that issue
and they haven't dealt with it over this
past 25 years they haven't brought about
reconciliation true reconciliation in
Northern Ireland uh it's just the
absence of violence here so therefore
it's not impacting on people in
Westminster and I I really regret that
because if you're genuine about peace
building then you have to recognize
where the difficulties are and certainly
the glorification is one of the things
that we need to tackle to flip down its
head Arlene though do you think the
unionist side has come to terms with its
own links to violence
well I don't know what you mean by the
union side because you see when Douglas
was first speaking I I was thinking to
myself uh people often in Northern when
they're looking at Northern Ireland
separate us into Catholic and Protestant
genius and nationalists actually it was
the law abiding people on one side and
the terrorists of all Hues on the other
side and the poor unfortunate Police
Service of Northern Ireland on the are
you see is that there was in the middle
trying to keep those people who were law
abiding safe from uh terrorists or
whatever Hugh on the other side so it it
it does get frustrating for those of us
who have lived through the troubles when
you hear people think that because I'm
from a unionist background that I would
in some way be in favor of
paramilitaries from a loyalist
disposition I'm not I think those people
shouldn't have been allowed out of
prison either frankly and should have
been dealt with in an effective way but
what happened in 1998 was the prisoners
from loyalist paramilitaries and
Republican paramilitaries were allowed
to walk free
and I think that huge thing that
happened then and Tony Blair has made
reference to it uh over this past week
and said it was a terribly difficult
thing but it had to be done well why did
it have to be done why did we not stick
by the rule of law and stick by the
justice system and deal with those
people who wanted to go out and murder
and kill instead we've allowed them to
go free and I think that there are
consequences for that of a generational
nature and we're seeing those
consequences now in places like
Londonderry unfortunately and it has to
be stopped by the way John if I may pick
up and just add to Arlene's Point yeah
of course I think this issue of
equivalency if it is extremely important
I mentioned in the piece I was no fan
ever of the late Reverend Ian Paisley I
thought he was a sort of sectarian bigot
loudmouth of a kind I really don't care
for but the idea even that there was a
sort of equivalency between Ian Paisley
and Martin McGinnis is absolutely
nonsense Reverend Ian Paisley was not
leading torture gangs on a nightly basis
was not getting people to come back to
Northern Ireland in order to murder them
like Martin McGinnis did on on occasions
we can prove the way we have audio
recordings and much more
um and as and as for the The Wider I
just go again on this issue of it
because it's it's as Arlene said yes
there's a sort of ease about making the
equivalency well all sides Etc I'm
talking about the specific thing that
for instance uh remind me so earlier
that Michael Stone was that the madman
yeah yeah take example of Michael Stone
Michael Stone carried out a set of
sectarian killings uh um in Northern
Ireland including the famously the uh
attack in the cemetery
um of the uh you know during the funeral
of the of the bodies of the people who
were brought back from Gibraltar now
Michael Stone was a classic example of a
sort of a radical terrorist extremist
from from the other side okay here's the
thing like nobody is lording Michael
Stone
he isn't in a devolved assembly he was
not made as Martin McGuinness was a
deputy first Minister he um was not in
charge of Education in Northern Ireland
at any point
um nobody thinks it's some incredibly
difficult to test to condemn him
we get back to this point that you know
as I mentioned in the piece the current
head of shin feiner the leader of the
opposition in the Irish parliament in
Dublin is taken to be bloodied and pay
homage to Sean Russell a Nazi and former
Ira leader in the 1940s who died on a
German Uber for once the use of the term
Nazi in 2023 is not hyperbole the
current head of shin Fein Mary Lou
McDonald is taken to pay homage at the
Statue of a murderer who was a Nazi who
was leading a buyer campaign against
British cities as the luftwaffe was
bombing those same British cities
and Mary Lou McDonald has to pay homage
why is it what is it about this movement
that means that you still have to pay
homage to Nazis and terrorists and
killers and bombers if you are to rise
in the ranks of the movement does nobody
see the problem here you know this is
what I would like us to see addressed
and I've said before to endless Northern
Ireland ministers you know they've been
endless inquiries inquiry after inquiry
and everybody could have one but somehow
it doesn't get to the root of the
problem
so turning to the Future Arlene do you
know that poison still exists that sort
of glorification of violence and so on
uh do you have any hope for the future
of Northern Ireland do you think this
can be resolved
look uh I've been a politician in
Northern Ireland since I was a teenager
and I think that you have to be an
optimist if you're a politician in
Northern Ireland and I am an optimist
the good people of Northern Ireland
those people who get up every morning go
to work and want Northern Ireland to be
a success will make it a success but
that doesn't deal with the issues that
are still there a remnants from our past
which are still infecting what's
happening here today and that has to be
dealt with and I think instead of
allowing uh Shin fin members to say that
they're just speaking their truth and
they're just remembering their Patriot
dead they should be called out and it
should be pointed out that it is morally
objectionable to Lord people who went
out to murder their neighbors for no
other reason than they put on a uniform
to try and protect citizens in Northern
Ireland that was it and indeed on many
occasions along the border all you had
to be was a Protestant to get taken out
because you maybe had a Farmland that
was near to the border and they wanted
to have it for them uh sold in a
particular way so
look all of that sectarianism all of the
glorification of terrorism must be
called out if we're to make any progress
in reconciling in in a true way in
Northern Ireland and not just talking
about reconciliation
um and if it's a as if it's a nice thing
to do and middle class people go along
and they have a nice time together and
not seen in somewhere to be
reconciliation reconciliation is about
calling out the difficulties and the
real challenges and not just trying to
paper over the cracks and therefore we
have to call out what's wrong and for me
what is wrong is about the past
glorification of terrorism which
continues to infect what's happening
today
thank you very much Alan and thank you
Douglas
next Louise Perry writes the cover piece
for this week's magazine about the
ethical dilemmas of surrogacy
cancerous surrogacy ever be done in a
way that is best for the mother and the
baby Louise joins me now
thank you Louise for joining us on
spectator TV to discuss your fascinating
cover piece on the ethics of surrogacy
now to start us off just for readers who
are probably maybe not as familiar with
the landscape what what is the current
situation in the UK at the moment when
it comes to surrogacy and and how we
different from other countries uh so we
permit altruistics surrogacy in this
country we don't have paid surrogacy
um uh uh intended parents are allowed to
reimburse surrogates for certain
expenses and in practice sometimes what
happens is that money is slightly passed
onto the table so you end up with a de
facto paid Arrangement but that's not
really legal
um and at the moment this is the crucial
thing that the law commission are hoping
to reform
you uh when the baby is born their
default legal parents are the surrogate
mother and her spouse if she has one and
intended parents have to go through the
um a parental order process which can
take several months in order to be
legally the parents of the child even if
the child is living with them etc etc
um this means as well that if surrogate
mothers change their minds
I want to keep the baby which they
sometimes do uh it's easier for them to
do so because they are sort of by
default the legal parent what the law
commission's reforms would do is they
would reverse that assumption so that at
Birth the default legal parents would be
the intended parents and the surrogate
mother would have the option to
um rescind her consent and apply for a
parental order herself but it would be
that much more difficult particularly
remembering that there's often quite a
big sort of uh class differential
between intended parents and surrogate
mothers even in altruistic Arrangements
it's more common for surrogate mothers
to be less wealthy less well-educated
have less access to things like legal
representation which would make securing
custody easier right and so some people
will say to that at the moment we have a
bit of a sort of legal limbo when the
baby is born and before it's adopted by
the new parents and it kind of leaves
everyone in bit of No Man's Land
including the surrogate mother I mean
what did what do you say to that in that
in that it should be simplified and made
easier in that I got
well that's just the nature of surrogacy
that it's enormously complicated legally
emotionally physically everything you
know because often what you're talking
about here is maybe as many as five
different parents of different kinds you
know you can have an egg donor a sperm
donor a gestational surrogate meaning a
woman who isn't actually genetically
related to the baby and two legal
parents so you've got a lot of different
adults in the mix all of whom have
different relationships to the child I
think it's
fanciful to think that you could make
that simple you know and also I don't
think that we are currently most
European countries are actually very
restrictive on surrogacy
um a lot of European countries just ban
it outright either in its altruistic or
its commercial forms we are probably the
most
um almost the most liberal certainly in
Western Europe
so what we would be doing by adopting
the reforms proposed by the law
commission would be to move towards a
much more American model you know not
fully commercializing as in say
California but definitely moving in that
direction
um in that we would be giving more
rights and more sort of legal support
and sanction to the intended parents and
actually
um
treating the surrogate mother as much
less like a mother you know much less
like any other woman who's giving birth
and much more like
I mean basically as I argue in the piece
as a sort of vessel really with no
actual
um relationship to the child at all
which I think is a misrepresentation of
what pregnancy actually involves
emotionally and physically for both
mother and baby and am I right to say
that you would prefer us to be a bit
more in line with the European situation
or do you think the status quo we have
now is is right the type of surrogacy
arrangement which I think would be the
most ethical would be one where
surrogate mothers continue having to
have a relationship with the baby
so there are some circumstances where
that might happen you know like a a
sister giving birth
on behalf of her infertile sister or
something along those lines where yes it
is emotionally complicated but that you
know the the surrogate mother remains in
the child's life there isn't this abrupt
um breaking of maternal infant Bond so
you know I'm tempted to say that that
that that kind of altruistic surrogacy
Arrangement
um
should be permitted the problem is it is
just very hard to regulate it's very
hard to prevent
um exploitation I mean there are a
couple of examples I give in the piece
of you know even if even if there's no
payment even if uh you know it see it
might seem from the outside as if it's
um extremely carefully regulated and
ethical you can still have exploitation
you can still have
um you know one of the cases I mentioned
the piece for instance is an
intellectually disabled woman who was
sort of tricked into doing this on
behalf of a couple and we know I mean I
I probably don't need to go into detail
with listeners about how how ugly
commercial surrogacy can look
um I just think that this whole industry
is is deeply suspect and I think that
any move towards wanting to liberalize
the law on it in this country as it is
moving the wrong direction
um you mentioned in your piece as well
it's really interesting about the sort
of even when the surrogate mother isn't
biologically related to the child
they're giving birth to there's a huge
sort of biological connection they have
with their child and that that's quite
an extreme thing to break up can you
tell us a bit about that please
yeah so the argument that you'll often
get from people who are Defenders of the
industry is they'll say that surrogate
mother's gestational surrogate mothers
so that is you know um when there's a
separate egg donor
um aren't related to the child so you
know why would you care basically about
their their their relationship with that
child or or indeed the child's
relationship with them you know why
would you want her to remain in the
child's life why would you want the
child to have the option of
um knowing the and being known by the
woman who he gave them life
um
I think what's kind of
curious about this view to say that
basically the only thing that really
matters is a genetic connection and the
fact that this woman has like grown this
child in her body this child's entire
experience of life until birth has been
inside this woman's body you know when
newborns are born they can't even see
properly but the only thing that they
know is is the the smell and the touch
of their mothers and we know as I
mentioned in the piece that newborns
experience
um intense stress when they're separated
from their mothers at Birth
the fact that there's no genetic
connection doesn't lessen that
emotional connection at Birth and I
think in a weird kind of way it's
extraordinarily sexist to say that the
only thing that matters is is a genetic
connection because in a way what you're
doing there is you're saying that
actually the sort of Father type
relationship the the the giving of
genetic material but not actually
um just dating giving birth to a child
that's the connection that matters you
know and actually what women do
meaningless you know throw it away like
who cares I think that there's something
you know I I don't normally use this
word but I think there's something
actually extraordinarily patriarchal
about taking that view of what pregnancy
actually means on an emotional and a
physical level that's very interesting
um what would you say there is the sort
of more libertarian view which says that
everyone involved if everyone involved
is sort of able to consent and they make
this decision knowing what they're
getting into then it shouldn't sort of
be the state's jobs to get involved and
tell them what to do I mean what would
you what would you say to that kind of
view
on that basis you could permit the
buying and selling of organs right which
some Libertarians do
um and all sorts of other um uh human
body parts and all sorts of other acts
which we we don't permit people to do
you know
um
I'm not a Libertarian I think that we
should have social guardrails I think
that the state is in the business of
protecting people's
emotional well-being physical well-being
and sometimes that means
um actually putting limits on the things
that we can legally consent to and you
know the other big factor here that no
one wants to talk about is is the
well-being of the child who doesn't
consent to any of this and to say that
um you know the the UK government gives
sanction to an industry that Engineers
the separation of mother and infant
makes it impossible for children to have
relationships to with the women who give
them life long term
I
yeah I mean no one it seems is thinking
about the fact that
um children
often desperately crave that that
relationship even into adulthood and
what what surrogacy does is it basically
prevents them from having it right from
the get-go I mean it's obviously a very
sensitive area but you know
we'd often say no like no pregnancy
would be perfect there's obviously
always going to be some things that are
not done that are quite maybe most
beneficial to a child I mean do you say
you know we live in an imperfect world I
mean some would say you know these
children will be raised in happy
families and that their benefit is going
to be much greater in general than if
they weren't born I mean what what do
you say to that
it's true that you know life is
imperfect but I don't think that's
sort of um any reason to make it any
less perfect than it already is I mean I
take the case of adoption you know we
know that there are cases where children
have to be adopted have to be removed
from their from their from their mothers
at Birth
um
those are tragedies and they cause
emotional
harm to everyone involved long term and
they are in incredibly sort of closely
monitored by social services and are
seen as an act of Last Resort
what surrogacy does is it sets out from
the get-go to engineer that situation
for no good reason except for the fact
that the intended parents would like to
would like to have a child in that
fashion would prefer to do that than to
adopt or Foster or like whatever other
options are available
I just think that the inconsistency
there
is really striking
um and it's because I don't think that
actually the surrogacy arrangement
really takes account of the child's best
interest at all I think it's actually
all to do with the desires of the
intended parents I mean if we take that
to its logical conclusion Louise that
does kind of suggest that
gay men couples who can't have children
shouldn't be able to have a biological
child are you kind of comfortable with
that tension
what some gay couples do including
friends of mine and I think that this is
a often a good option is to
um sort of gay couples to pair up with
lesbian couples
and to to to to you know do the
traditional well semi-traditional turkey
baster approach rather than the full
um full uh IVF process and the
um the mums who give birth to these
children are the ones who have custody
of them and children are with them but
obviously they have a very strong
relationship with
um their fathers who live locally and
involved in their lives you know I there
are ways of doing this which actually I
think protect everyone's interests and
mean that the child has had all of their
all of their biological parents in their
lives and is never removed from their
mothers and so on so I don't think I I
you know I'm not Auntie at all LGBT
families it's just that surrogacy as a
particular method of creating LGBT
families I think has
um enormous ethical problems and do you
worry as well about the sort of wider
exploitation of women if this is made a
bit more lacks than the rules around it
are made more Lacks
yeah we know that there have been
um many cases of women being
mistreated in the service industry
um I am actually my podcast made mother
matriarch
um I had uh Jennifer Lal who's a former
nurse and and
um surrogacy campaigner on this week and
she's done a lot of research into the
health risks associated with surrogacy
which can be
um really very shocking
um there have been women who have died
in America as a consequence of of sorry
you see
um that the rate of complications is
much higher for several reasons
um as I mentioned in my piece rates of
postnatal depression are higher for
surrogate mothers there are there are
lots of um ways in which surrogate
mothers can can suffer
um as a consequence of surrogacy and
um
and and and we know that there's all
sorts of cases of um
manipulation and exploitation of women
who desperately want the money and don't
necessarily know what they're actually
getting themselves into brilliant thank
you very much Louise that's fascinating
now continuing on the topic of surrogacy
we're going to speak to someone with a
different point of view now Kim cotton
made history in 1985 as the first woman
in the UK to carry a baby for an
anonymous couple she's been working in
the surrogacy world for 35 years now and
joins me on the show
Kim thank you so much for coming on
spectator TV and to discuss this
fascinating subject and I know one
that's very personal for you
um to start us off can you tell us a bit
about your experiences as a surrogate
mother um I believe you're the first
surrogate in the UK is that right
um yes I was a surrogate in 1985
um actually working through a commercial
agency
um from the USA at that time
um and I've never expected all the
funeral that would um her birth would
create
um and
um six months later they rushed through
some laws to ban commercial surrogacy in
the UK which I actually totally agree
with and we've never changed on that
point you set up an organization now to
help surrogates find find potential
adoptive parents I mean how different is
is the landscape now to to what when it
went when you were a surrogate
well we we launched cots on Mother's Day
in 1988 and so we've been going 35 years
now and in that time we've had
1115 births with another 10 pregnancies
um due this year
um and times have changed drastically
um back in the old days there was only
traditional surrogacy where the first
mother was actually the genetic mother
as well
um nowadays the um
because of IVF and and the science and
the step forward and the acceptability
of surrogacy now
um most of the surrogates choose to be
gestational surrogates which means they
can actually be have an embryo
transferred to them so when they give
birth they're not the genetic mother of
the child
right and your organization how does it
work so are you allowed to put
surrogates in touch with each other with
parents and that kind of thing or do you
have to be a bit more hands-off yeah
we have them screened and a potential
surrogate so we asked for a DBS check uh
GP report and they were referred to our
independent counselor so that they will
informed of the implications of any
journey and that they might start
um but the surrogate really is in the um
driving seat because she chooses who she
would like to work with because it's
very much about
um building up a friendship and a solid
Bond and it must be based on friendship
because there is no contract there's no
enforceable
um anything that can make her give up a
baby if she doesn't want to so you have
to make sure that the the relationship
that they have
um built up is built on very solid
foundations I see and so it seems like
your organization takes a lot of care to
make sure this is done as safely and as
as best as possible
um I think I'm right saying there's no
legal obligation to go through an
organization like yours at the moment do
you kind of worry that that when things
are done a different way there might be
more worrying outcomes or perhaps
exploitation and that kind of thing I I
think it's
um always best to go through an agency
because of the support and the guidance
that you get and it's really
hand-holding and it's a step-by-step
guide so you know as you go through the
transfer getting accepted at a clinic we
can help with all of those things
because it's a very lonely and it's a
very uh a traumatic journey to take and
people you know enter it with such
trepidation and worry that you know
belonging to an organization can
actually take some of that away but
obviously there are independent
groups that manage quite well
um but we always protect every party
from any exploitation if we can and
especially when it comes to finances do
I mean you mentioned the sort of the
trauma there um I presume you're
referring to particularly giving up the
baby for the Soviet mother
after it's been born I mean do you have
worries about the mothers that you
support through this that that you know
that's a huge a huge thing to do for
them and and possibly for the baby as
well
um I I don't think there's any effect on
a child at all to be quite honest I
think um
research has shown that surrogate
children actually flourish and do a lot
better than maybe the children born
through natural circumstances and
because this child is so wanted
um and they've taken such a lot of time
and money and effort to bring this child
into the world then they put an awful
lot into the raising of that child and
making sure that it's secure and safe
and a surrogate child will never find
out that they're a Thorogood child they
will just always have known that's our
way of thinking and that's the way it
should be there's no shock when they
find out all on the surrogate child and
often to be quite honest in most
circumstances the intending parents and
the surrogate mother will be in touch
for years after
[Music]
so it's an ongoing relationship and it's
like having an extended family so we
always feel special in that child's life
and um you know we're always known as a
tummy mummy so you encourage surrogates
to stay in touch with with the eventual
families that right
the best thing it's the best thing for
everybody because the surrogate can see
how life-changing her gift has been and
for the child you know it's just knowing
all parties involved with their um
coming into this world so it's it's a
win-win situation
and so this pieces these pieces were
running this week have kind of come
about because the law commission have
proposed changes to the law which will
make sort of the the contracts more
secure it'll make it easier for the to
hand the child over uh to the adoptive
parents I mean do you support those
changes that the law commission have put
forward
um I support a lot of the changes that
are being brought forward
um but there's some very sticky issues
that I don't
um
I I think
um yes I think Clinic
um organizations so we've got
organizations like ourselves being
licensed will be probably quite a good
thing
um but to be quite honest you know a lot
of the things that they're insisting
upon we do already we are very
self-regulating and we do take our role
in matching couples very seriously it's
a huge responsibility and
um My worry is always about the
well-being of a surrogate so we always
ensure that they are looked after for
several weeks and months after a child
is born and we're always there if they
need to talk but in most cases they are
really flying high on the sense of
achievement that they have their
experience it's it's a wonderful
wonderful thing to be a surrogant mother
and it's not just a a momentary feeling
of well-being it lasts for years because
the child is here for years
um do you worry all that the changes
might make it more difficult if a
surrogate mother does change their mind
and want to keep the child
it's you know what it's irrelevant now
we haven't had
um a surrogate change her mind in in
three decades those bad old days are
gone and quite honestly uh 99 of the
surrogate Journeys we do are are
gestational surrogacy so surrogates do
not go into surrogacy wanting to extend
their own family when they could
naturally have a child with someone they
love
um and choose you know why would you
keep a baby that has been specifically
um born
for the parents to take you know you
you'd be stabbing them in the back and
almost killing them
um with the trauma if you decided to
keep a child it just doesn't happen it's
not even a worry that I even think about
anymore that's really interesting thank
you very much Kim
and finally I'm joined Now by Professor
David abalafia professor emeritus of
Mediterranean history at the University
of Cambridge he's written for our
website about the strange way Cleopatra
has been portrayed in a new Netflix
series he joins me now
David thank you so much for joining us
on spectator TV now you wrote a
fantastic piece for coffeehouse this
week on a Netflix docu series called
African queens and in particular an
episode about Cleopatra was to show very
much portrays as a black African now 20
viewers who aren't as familiar with the
history of that time could you please
tell us a little bit about why you think
that is a very odd thing to do
well the reality is that Cleopatra she
was the last member of this dynasty the
ptolemaic Dynasty in Egypt which went
all the way back to the death of
Alexander the Great and the division of
Alexander's Empire among his Macedonian
generals so
um the result of that was a Greek
dynasty was established based in
Alexandria and are they by and large I
mean there's very little evidence that
they ever married anybody who wasn't
also Greek indeed sometimes
um brothers and sisters married which
was in Egyptian practice one that the
Greeks actually detested
um so uh really you know all the
evidence we have including also the
Visual Evidence because there are quite
a lot of portraits which are thought to
be a cleopatric you can't always be sure
show her looking very very Greek
um and uh most of in fact all her
predecessors apart from herself none of
them even spoke the Egyptian language
she's the first one to have learned the
Egyptian language because she wasn't
exceptionally intelligent uh individual
she she spoke in a great many languages
uh and you know she was very cultured uh
individual I mean that adoption of a
Cleopatra's adoption of Egyptian
identities was quite an interesting
story as well um though do you think she
might be guilty of cultural
appropriation if we look at it today
well in a sense yes the autonomies they
sort of took over the the way that the
pharaohs had behaved so we have for
instance a little relief of her
sacrificing to the god Batar and there
she's addressed she's dressed as a
pharaoh and you know that was part of
the image that Ptolemy has cultivated
and so they worshiped Egyptian gods they
also worshiped Greek gods and there was
even this God Called serapis It was a
sort of mixture of Greek and Egyptian
who'd been specially invented by the
tolerance really to sort of bring
together the communities uh so uh that
was certainly part of what she was but
but by and large these people were very
emphatically Greek I mean one of the
great things they did was they founded
this library in Alexandria which had you
know tens hundreds of thousands of of
books and which was predominantly Greek
literature which included other things
that included a translation of the Bible
in from from Hebrew into Greek but you
know the fact was it was a translation
into Greek that was the language that
Cleopatra would have used in talking to
Julius Caesar Marc Anthony
Etc she probably knew Latin but uh but
they knew Greek extremely well and that
was her native tongue um you mentioned
in your piece as well that Alexandria
didn't wasn't even possibly see itself
that much as an Egyptian city is that
right
indeed it's a very interesting feature
of Alexandria which apparently survived
right through well didn't survive but
was revived in the 19th century this
idea among alexandrians that they didn't
really live in Egypt and of course in a
way it was true it was a new city
founded by Alexander the Great and its
population contained enormous percentage
of Greeks and also very significant
percentage of Jews and the native
Egyptian population therefore was
something set marginalized so there was
this idea it was the phrase Alexandria
ad egyptum ad meaning Alexandra on the
edge of towards but not quite in Egypt
and it seems that this was something
which was in the 19th century also it
was a way in which these very mixed
communities because the city was full of
Greeks and Italians and so on again they
thought of themselves as actually part
of Europe rather than Africa
so we have all this evidence showing
that Cleopatra was very much from the
Greek world and so on was there has
there been any sort of scholarship to
sort of defend Netflix's point to
suggest that she's got maybe more like
this it might have been black for
example
well there's been a little bit I I I've
looked at various websites
um there was one from an American
University I have to say not a
university I'd heard of before but which
was very much defending the sort of
position I'm taking that yet she was
Macedonian it's it's as as
straightforward as that one of the most
interesting this isn't a scholarly
reaction but it's one of the most
interesting reactions actually comes
from an actress who is also playing
Cleopatra in a film which I believe is
being made at the moment and this is Gal
Gadot the Israeli actress who uh she
says Uh there's the truth of the matter
is that he was Macedonian because people
objected to her playing the role
um and the guardian even ran a piece
saying this was the headline Gal Gadot
as Cleopatra is a backward step for
Hollywood representation
but then they had to backtrack a bit
because they realized that she herself
came from the Middle East and she is a
sixth or seventh generation Israeli I
mean her ancestors lived in ottoman
Palestine so
um she's also actually from the region
the guardian got a little bit sort of
mixed up over all of this so there's a
rush every once a piece of Cleopatra
but it it set off a similar debate
actually the making of gadot's film made
set of similar debate three years ago to
the one that's been set off by Netflix
uh shouldn't she be played by a the
guardian wanted a North African uh act
uh
um it it doesn't reflect the historical
reality I mean to play a bit of Devil's
Advocate David do you think there's sort
of a case that you know often the
portrayals of Cleopatra are never going
to be perfectly accurate you mentioned
for example that her her beauty and
looks have often been mythologized and
she's very portrayed as a very beautiful
woman for example when when perhaps she
wasn't do you think there's a case for
saying that that the same can be applied
to race and it kind of doesn't matter
how she's portrayed
well you could say that in a way I mean
we've now become used since Bridgeton
and all these other things to people of
all sorts of ethnicities playing roles
that I mean it goes back a long way some
very distinguished uh actors you know
black actors in Shakespeare and so on
and and one doesn't notice it actually
after time watching this sort of thing I
think the problem here is that this is a
Netflix series about African queens and
it really is trying to make the point
and you know it's a perfectly valid
point there have been these Black
African queens who've played an
important role in the history of various
parts of the continent
um but Cleopatra is a very bad example
and it's this sort of hijacking of
somebody who's real interest lies in her
Greek cultural heritage and her Greek
ethnicity we're going to talk about race
but as this American University website
pointed out out a very good point you
can't really talk about race
um when you're dealing with the first
century BC that sort of language that is
language of the 20th 21st centuries it's
not language that really applies to the
Society of the time of Julius Caesar so
do you get the sense this is very much
placing our values back on the past and
and in this case
yes I mean it's an attempt to sort of
generate pride in the history of of
black people and to underline the fact
which is undoubtedly true that the
history of Africa particularly black
Africa has been so much ignored in the
past but one also has to bear in mind
that the history of the Northern parts
of Africa has often been much more
engaged with the Mediterranean and you
think of the Bourbons the berbers who
were for so long the majority population
all along that stretch from Morocco to
the edges of Egypt
um they um many of them very
fair-skinned you know lots of blue eyes
and so on I I mean you just can't start
applying these criteria based on skin
color it just doesn't work and if you
were to go to the deep south of Africa
you would find you know some of the very
ancient peoples would be the Bushmen and
so on much lighter-skinned than the
population that came in in more recent
centuries skin color is is an
irrelevance really in in trying to
understand the history of of the
continent brilliant that's fascinating
thank you very much David
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel click the Subscribe button at
the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon so you never miss any of our
videos
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]